l und
[Musik]
prcht schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus was geht dir gerade durch
den Kopf ich habe gerade den neuen
Asterix gelesen die weiße Iris ne die
weiße Iris also Asterix hat ja bei mir
lange Tradition also die ersten Asterix
Hefte die kamen bei uns Ende der 60er
Jahre auf da gab's gerade drei oder vier
auf Deutsch da konnte ich noch nicht
lesen und dann hat mein Vater die
vorgelesen und hat mir die ganzen
Zusammenhänge erklärt wer Julius Cesar
war und die Galia und so weiter und
seitdem hat Asterix unsere Familie
begleitet ne mit fünf Kindern und alle
haben Asterix gelesen und so Asterix
Redensarten die spielten bei uns eine
große Rolle zu Hause und deswegen lasse
ich mir bis heute keinen neuen Asterix
entgehen in dem neuen Asterix kommt ein
Guru der Moderne der einem was
überwogenes und Achtsamkeit und so
weiter erzählt und der CO Coach ein
Coach Coach ein motivationscoach und
achtsamkeitscoach und so ich kenne gar
nicht alle Begriffe die man dafür
inzwischen verwendet und der stärkt die
Kampfkraft der römischen Legionen durch
positives Denken und der zerstört die
Kampf g durch genau das gleiche positive
Denken super und in der spaltet das Dorf
ist ja immer in letzter Zeit so viel von
gesellschaftlicher Spaltung die Rede und
genau diese Spaltung findet im
gallischen Dorf statt weil die einen
lehnen den total ab die wollen bleiben
was sie sind und die anderen fangen an
sich zu bezirzen und zu verhexen lassen
dass man ja eigentlich keine
Wildschweine essen soll und dass man
sich ja nicht hauen soll und dann sagt
da zu Gute mene gute mene ist die
ziemlich bösbockige Frau von majestic ja
diantippe quasi von majesti ja berühmt
für ihre schlechte Laune genau als sie
mal wieder gerade so loslegt zu fluchen
und zu schimpfen und dann sagt er zu ihr
oh du funkelst von
innen und ich denke den kann man sich
für jeden beziehungskonflikt merken ja
ah guck mal du funkelst schon wieder von
ih ich frage mich gerade wozu das führt
führt das sozusagen zur Besänftigung
oder zum Reflex du nimmst mich schon
wieder nicht ernst das kann natürlich
auch sein gute er das zweite also es
geht um es geht um Achtsamkeit es geht
also irgendjemand schriebt den schönen
Satz der Zeitgeist bahnt sich
unaufhörlich seinen Weg ja also Visus
versus ja ist ja der oberste heeresarzt
ja kommt sozusagen auf die Idee
positives Denken und gesunde Ernährung
soll jetzt Schwung in die Truppe bringen
ne neuen Schwung und dann geht der
wildschweinkonsum auch bei den gallan
zurück stattdessen wird jetzt plötzlich
Obst und Gemüse gegessen und so weiter
dann gibt's glaube ich wie heißt der
Fischhändler verleinix
verleinix verkauft plözlich frischen
Fisch und so weiter und haut sich auch
nicht mehr hier mit mit wie heißt der
der Schmied automati automatic so super
herrlich und ich fand das ein gutes ein
guten Anlass Richard um mit dir mal über
etwas zu sprechen von dem ich das Gefühl
habe das greift immer mehr um sich
Stelle das auch fest im Gespräch mit
Freunden ich habe das Gefühl da gibt's
gerade so ein ganz großen Rückschritt
und je schneller der gesellschaftliche
Fortschritt der vermeint
voranschreitet desto größer wird dieser
Rückschritt die Zeit titelt dann
plötzlich Sehnsucht nach Trost und so
weiter also ich habe das Gefühl wenn der
Fortschritt zu schnell geht das hast du
so ähnlich mal hier ausgedrückt ja wenn
der Fortschritt zu schnell geht dann
kommt der Rückschritt in Wahrheit weil
die Leute dieses Tempo nicht nur nicht
mitgehen können sondern sie wollen es
auch tatsächlich nicht stellst du das
auch fest ich stell das auch fest also
wenn in dem gallischen Dorf sich
automati und verleiniks nicht mehr hauen
dürfen oder hauen wollen oder wenn der
Fischhändler auf einmal frischen Fisch
was man von ihm jetzt nicht gewohnt ist
verkauft dann verliert er ja bis zu
einem gewissen gerade seine Identität ja
weil seine Identität besteht darin a
rauflustig zu sein und B een Fisch zu
verkaufen und natürlich ist das schön
sich nicht zu prügeln und frische Fische
sind auch schön aber das führt dann dazu
dass es eine Art Identitätsverlust gibt
und ich glaube das ist das wovor viele
Menschen Angst haben wenn der
Fortschritt zu schnell geht haben sie
Angst dass sie sich in ihrer Welt in
ihrer Wirklichkeit in dem Land in dem
sie leben plötzlich nicht mehr heimisch
fühlen also es entsteht eine eine
gewisse Obdachlosigkeit innere
Obdachlosigkeit und die geht häufig
einher mit starkem Widerstand und ich
denke dass wir in so einer Zeit sind
manchmal hat man ja das Gefühl die Zeit
läuft so langsam wie ein Reitkamel so in
den 80er Jahren in den 90er Jahren das
war jedenfalls mein subjektiver Eindruck
und das hat sich durch das Internet
verändert das hat sich dann durch das
Smartphone verändert und heute leben wir
irgendwie in einer ganz anderen Welt als
vor 20 oder 30 Jahren ja ich habe neuch
einen schönen Begriff dafür gelesen
Generation kacho das fand ich gut das
trifft es perfekt und diese
Beschleunigung die da die davon statten
gegangen ist das ist glaube ich das was
den Menschen Angst macht und selbst
denen die sich für für wie soll man
sagen für sehr weit gereist und für für
Weltenbürger halten selbst denen macht
das mittlerweile Angst da gibt so eine
ich glaube der der der Soziologe Steffen
mau oder nennt es so eine eine
veränderungsmüdigkeit das stelle ich
auch fest die Leute sagen ja okay
verstehe ich alles und alles in Ordnung
und wir sind moderne Menschen und wir
sollten da mitmachen und die
Digitalisierung und das iPhone und so
weiter
aber ich brauche mal ein bisschen Zeit
ich muss mal ein bisschen durchatmen es
gibt ja diese diese berühmte Geschichte
ich weiß nicht ob sie erfunden ist ne
von dem Native American Chief der an die
Ostküste gekommen ist irgendwie mit dem
Flugzeug und der dann erstmal Hal zu
einer Konferenz und dann erstmal
irgendwie eine Woche in seinem
Hotelzimmer meditiert haben soll bis
seine Seele nachgekommen ist ja ja und
die dieses Bild trifft natürlich relativ
gut auf die Gesellschaft zu man das
Gefühl die Veränderung geht sehr viel
schneller als die Seele nachkommen kann
Menschen sind ja sehr sehr
anpassungsfähig ich meine überleg mal
was Menschen in ihrer Geschichte was für
Kulturen und in was für Umwelten die
gelebt haben ja auf dem langen Weg von
der ostafrikanischen Savanne bis in die
Gegenwart das heißt also Menschen passen
sich an sehr sehr viele Dinge an aber
nicht alle sehr schnell meistens auch
die älteren nicht sehr schnell und wenn
du dein Leben eigentlich bis lang ganz
gut gefunden hast dann ist also das die
Androhung einer großen Veränderung und
ein change und so weiter für viele Leute
eben dann eher eine Drohung als ein
Versprechen ja es ist richtig genau und
und die weil du das gerade dieses Bild
gerade benutzt hast das so schön ja die
meine Seele muss Nachkommen ich äh hab
neulich gelesen dass die Geschichte der
Beschleunigung ist ja nicht so eine alte
Geschichte also diese diese enorme
Beschleunigung beginnt ja in der
Geschichte der Menschheit also für uns
vor ungefähr was wird zu sagen 200 150
Jahren und dann noch mal mit zunehmendem
Tempo wirklich in den letzten nicht mal
Jahrzehnten sondern wirklich in den
letzten Jahren mhm ja also ich glaube
eine ganz große Veränderung war die
erste industrielle Revolution aber die
vollzog sich ja über viele Jahrzehnte
hinweg das war nicht so eine ganz
ruckartige Veränderung nur in wenigen
Gebieten ne erst in England und später
malim Ruhrgebiet und so und diese zweite
industrielle Revolution so um 1900 rum
als die Elektrifizierung kam ja und als
die Autos kamen und die fahrstchüle
kamen und in USA wurden wolkenk gebaut
und und Telefonen und plötzlich
veränderte sich die ganze Welt und damit
veränderte sich mit dem technischen
Fortschritt die Umgangsform die Mode ja
also die die Rolle der Frau in der
Gesellschaft veränderte sich
zumindestens in den Großstädten in den
20er Jahren es kam Dinge auch wie die
Psychoanalyse ja die den Menschen auf
einmal völlig anders erklärte es
entstanden die Ideologien ja radikale
Weltanschauungen und diese diese Suche
nach sowas zu ein festen Halt oder nach
einem neuen Weltbild indem sich die alte
Seele wiederfindet und eine der besten
Erklärungen für das was sich da abspielt
hat Ernst Bloch ne also der große
Philosoph Ernst Bloch essaist ernstbloch
der hat ein Buch geschrieben in den 30er
Jahren das heißt Erbschaft dieser Zeit
und in dem hat er genau das beschrieben
worüber wir gerade reden also diese
unterschiedlichen Tempi während die
einen voransturmen und die ganze Welt
neu machen wollen gibt es eben die
anderen die stürmen mit dem gleichen
Tempo in die Gegenrichtung und des
beschreibt er wir haben sowas wie die
die die Gleichzeitigkeit des
Ungleichzeitigen also gleichzeitig leben
Menschen in verschiedenen Welten die
einen wollen nach vorne die anderen
wollen wieder zurück und das ist immer
eine hochgefährliche gemengellage für
eine Gesellschaft und ich glaube dass
das ziemlich gut beschreibt die Zeit in
der wir heute leben der Satz dazu ist
total interessant aus Erbschaft dieser
Zeit ne nicht alle sind im selben jetzt
da ja sie sind es nur äußerlich ne
dadurch dass Sie heute hier zu en sind
aber damit leben sie noch nicht mit den
anderen zugleich was für ein kluger
Gedanke ja also wenn du jetzt wenn du
jetzt in in in einem kleinen Dorf lebst
ja und sagen wir bist Landwirt ja und
auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen
Seite du studierst an der
humbolduni dann lebst du in zwei Welten
die fast keine Gemeinsamkeit mehr haben
also in der Welt an der humbolduni
fällst du ganz dumm auf wenn du die
wogniskultur nicht kennst du fällst dumm
auf wenn du nicht genderst und so weiter
in dem kleinen Dorf würdest du damit
auffallen wenn du genderst also
sozusagen es geht gar nicht
gegensätzlicher in der Entwicklung und
eigentlich müsste es ja in so einer
Situation die Aufgabe der Politik sein
zu vermitteln versuchen zu verhindern
dass das ganze nicht an allen Ecken und
Enden auseinander fliegt oder dass die
Gesellschaft
ausfranzt aber soweit ich das sehe ist
die Politik mit dieser Rolle auch völlig
überfordert mhm können wir vielleicht
gleich noch mal drüber reden aber dieses
sozusagen die die die Gleichzeitigkeit
des Ungleichzeitigen ne wenn man sich
das mal historisch anschaut dann findest
Du total interessante Beispiele dafür
also historische Ereignisse die alle zur
gleichen Zeit stattgefunden haben ca
2500 vor Christus der Bau der Pyramiden
mhm ja und gleichzeitig gab es immer
noch die Jagd auf Mammuts es ist irre
oder 80 nach Christus in Rom wird das
kolosseäum gebaut größtes bis heute
größtes Amphitheater der Welt und
gleichzeitig ungefähr 80 nach Christus
so glauben Bibelforscher ent steht das
Lukasevangelium genau Zeit der
Evangelien so genau dann 71 auch total
interessant Frauen Stimmrecht in der
Schweiz ja so Schweizer Männer haben
dann endlich ein Einsehen und sagen okay
jetzt dürfen auch Frauen auf Bundesebene
wählen und so weiter damit ist die
Schweiz im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern
spät dran ne Australien glaube ich schon
um 1900 Finnland auch so um 1900 und
gleichzeitig 71 während die Schweizer
sagen okay jetzt dürfen auch Frauen
wählen fährt ein buagy auf dem Mond
herum Apollo 15 ich ich GL ich glaub
sogar der der letzte Kanton der das
Frauenwahlrecht zugelassen hat war der
Kanton innerroden und das war Mitte der
80er Jahre und da das war das waren
sozusagen das letzte gallische Dorf ja
mitten in der Schweiz oderwezische Dorf
sozus der letzte Kanton in dem auch in
den 70er Jahren noch durchweg geil das
Frauen nicht wählen durften und das
wurde also erst Mitte der 80er Jahre
geändert ja also nicht alle sind Demel
jetzt da ne das kann man wohl sagen
genau das kann man sagen oder 75 z.B
zwei Beispiele habe ich noch für dich 75
entsteht Microsoft ne Bill Gates und
Paul allen Stellen sozusagen den größten
die größte Softwarefirma der Welt auf
die Beine und im selben Jahr stirbt in
Spanien Franco ja ja also das Ende des
Frankismus faschistische Diktatur
zumindest in den ersten Jahren ganz
eindeutig das alles findet gleichzeitig
statt und dann besonders interessant 81
fliegt das erste Space Shuttle ins All
ja das war der Jungfernflug damals also
das war ja damals die Idee wir bauen ein
Raumfahrzeug dass wir wieder verwenden
können dass wieder zurückkommt und
endete dann ja ne als die Columbia ich
habe diese Bilder habe ich immer noch
tief in meinem Kopf mit der Lehrerin an
Bord Bo boah wie furchtbar 2003 ne alle
alle Astronauten sterben die ganze
Besatzung findet den Tod weil das Ding
einfach explodiert und im selben Jahr
Mauretanien offiziell die Sklaverei ab
ich finde wir sollten wir sollten uns
mal ein ganzen Podcast lang auch über
die die außenpolitische Ungleichheit
unterhalten weil die natürlich auch ein
wahnsinnig spannendes Thema ist total
aber innenpolitisch wird sie halt auch
größer und das ist ja erstaunlich weil
man würde ja denken in einer
Gesellschaft wo alle ein Internet haben
wo alle sich informieren können ja
müsste doch eigentlich das gegenteilige
eintret also die Leute müssten doch
immer mehr Punkte haben wo sie sich über
das gleiche verständ en können und
müssten eigentlich zunehmend in der
gleichen Welt leben weil sie
informationsmäßig nicht mehr voneinander
abgeschottet sind wie früher richtig
aber es tritt das Gegenteil ein das
heißt also sozusagen die die
turboinationsgesellschaft verhindert
nicht dass die Menschen in völlig
unterschiedlichen Welten leben weil man
sich eben aus diesen Welten die einem
digital angeboten werden auch das
raussucht was zu dem passt wie man
sowieso schon seine Innenwelt möbliert
hat weil du das gerade erwähnst mit der
Gleichzeitigkeit also der technologische
Fortschritt hätte doch da eigentlich und
das ja das Faszinierende am Internet
eine eine eine gigantische Veränderung
bringen müssen ich habe Norbert Lammert
mal zugehört ehemaliger
Bundestagspräsident brillanter Redner
auch brillanter Denker der sagte die
eigentliche Revolution am Internet ist
ja genau das die gleichzeitige
Verfügbarkeit von Information überall in
in derselben Sekunde wenn du so willst
also du musst nicht mehr irgendeine eine
Droschke auf den Weg schicken irgendeine
Postkutsche auf den Weg schicken du
musst nicht Flaschenpost irgendwo ins
Wasser werfen du brauchst keinen
reitenden Boten sondern du hast die
möglich der irgendwann Wochen später
ankommt sondern Du kannst sozusagen
heute durch Technologie dafür sorgen
dass eine Information eine Nachricht
sich gleichzeitig in Echtzeit auf dem
gesamten Globus verbreitet ja das heißt
da hätte sich eigentlich was das angeht
etwas verändern müssen weil die
technologischen Voraussetzungen
plötzlich ganz andere sind aber in
unseren Köpfen hat da interessanterweise
etwas ganz anderes stattgefunden ja da
passiert das was ganz oft passiert die
Technik ist hundtm schneller als das
menschliche Bewusstsein so ja und führt
dann im Zweifelsfall überhaupt nicht zu
dem erwünschten Effekt man hätte ja auch
sagen können andere technische
Revolutionen die es vorher schon gegeben
hat die Verbindung der Länder durch
Eisenbahnen z.B oder Telegrafie ja oder
irgendwann Telefonie alles das hätte ja
auch dazu führen können dass es dann
vielleicht
viele Möglichkeit gibt um Kriege zu
verhindern in die man dann nicht mehr
stolpert weil man sich ja verständigen
kann weil es so viele neue Austausch und
Kommunikationskanäle gibt und weil die
Wirtschaft sich globalisiert und man
gemeinsame Interessen findet und alles
das ist überhaupt nicht passiert also
die sagen mal die die
menschheitsgeschichtlichen Entwicklung
die man mit dem technischen Fortschritt
verbunden hat dass man immer gesagt hat
die Technik verbindet die Menschen alle
miteinander mit der Hoffnung dass sie
dann besser miteinander klar kommmen
oder ihre ihre Konfliktlinien ausräumen
können genau dieses Versprechen an die
Technik hat sich bisher überhaupt nicht
be it ich habe immer das Gefühl die
technische Entwicklung ist einfach sehr
sehr viel schneller als der Reif Gerrad
der Menschen ja ich meine es gibt
eine wunderbare Analogie ne als als die
Eisenbahn plötzlich da war da haben sich
Leute Sorgen gemacht dass ungefähr Tempo
30 ne ab Tempo 30 wird's gefährlich für
das menschliche Gehirn man hatte die
Sorge das führt zu Gehirnerweichung ja
also zu viel Geschwindigkeit ist nicht
gut für den Kopf und interessanterweise
hat's dann ein bisschen gedauert dass
die ersten die da einstiegen den wurden
den wurde schlecht weil sie den Fehler
gemacht haben immer auf die Gleise
runter zustarren ja das ist natürlich
ein tödlicher Fehler ich bin jemand der
sehr schnell sehekrank wird quasi mir
wird unfassbar schnell schlecht selbst
in einem Tretboot vor Rimini wird mir
schlecht und deswegen kann ich das sehr
gut nachfühlen bis man dann gelernt hat
sozusagen den Horizont in der Ferne zu
fixieren und dann war das Thema erledigt
aber diese Angst vor Geschwindigkeit
diese Angst vor Beschleunigung sehr
interessant hat sich sozusagen B Bren
mit der Einführung der Eisenbahn und im
Grunde ist das eigentlich wenn du so
willst schon ein ja ein ein starkes Bild
dafür dass wir glaube ich zurecht auf
eine Art zu viel Geschwindigkeit zu
viele Umdrehungen zu viel Tempo in
unserem Leben fürchten ich glaube wir
haben da einen guten Instinkt dafür dass
uns das eigentlich nicht gut tut und
wenn man sich das mal anschaut ich habe
noch nicht drüber nachgedacht
evolutionär war es doch so die Dinge
haben so lange gedauert wie sie gedauert
haben es gab sozusagen nicht den
perfekten von Google Maps ausgerechneten
Weg Irgendwohin sondern du folgst
vielleicht dem Flusslauf der so durch
die Landschaft mehandert und irgendwann
bist du da wo du sein willst Menschen
hatten Zeit heute ist das völlig anders
und ich ich ähm habe auf vielen Reisen
nach Grönland z.B habe ich das immer
wieder erfahren wie anders man sozusagen
das große Thema Zeit und und die Frage
wie du dich in dieser Zeit bewegst wie
anders man das betrachten kann
Grünländer grünländische Jäger vor allen
Dingen das sind augenblicksmenschen die
Leben völlig im Augenblick und ich habe
öfter erlebt du du machst dich gerade
fertig du du du spannst die Hunde ein
und so weiter und es ist alles auf dem
Schlitten verstaut und jetzt soll es
losgehen eine lange Reise Tagesreise
irgendwohin und dann kommt einer der
länger nicht gesehen wurde im Dorf ein
Freund und der kommt plötzlich zu Besuch
und dann sind die
in jeder Sekunde immer bereit gewesen zu
sagen okay komm dann fahren wir morgen
egal jetzt kommt der gerade jetzt reden
wir ein bisschen trinken wir Kaffee
jetzt Rauchen wir eine Zigarette und das
fand ich immer so schön sich dieses
völlig einlassen auf den Moment auf die
Situation das kannst du dir leisten in
einer Gesellschaft in der Zeit keine
Rolle spielt was müsste in meinem Leben
passieren dass ich alles stehen und
liegen lasse den ganzen verplanten Tag
stehen und liegen lasse und mich jetzt
exakt auf einen Freund Situation ein
Gespräch einzulassen das so lange dauert
wie es dauert und wenn es zwei Tage
dauert auch egal ja also du hast ja also
gerade das Beispiel erzählt hast von den
den Leuten die die Flüsse entlang
gewandert sind und dann einen Platz
gefunden haben wo sie gesagt haben oh
hier ist es gut hier bleibe ich so wo
ist denn heute im hektischen Leben was
du gerade beschrieben hast der Platz an
dem die Leute sagen hier bleibe ich ich
meine das nicht nur den Ort ich meine
das auch keine weitere Entwicklung mehr
ne dass ich sag so so wie das Leben
jetzt ist so soll es bleiben so soll das
bleiben weil wir leben ja in einem
permanenten veränderungszwang ne wir
müssen uns immer wieder neu erfinden
immer wieder neu anpassen auch weil der
technische aber eben auch der kulturelle
Fortschritt uns unausgesetzt zur
Anpassung zwingt und deswegen können wir
ja gar nicht diesen diesen
grönlandstatus wieder erreichen dass wir
sagen so jetzt schnaufen wir mal in Ruhe
durch und jetzt bleiben wir ewig da wo
wir sind und man könnte diese
Konfliktlinie die ich vorhin beschrieben
habe als Beispiel das Dorf auf der einen
Seite und die humbolduni auf der anderen
Seite auch daran festmachen dass es sehr
viele Leute gibt die Leben ein Leben und
sagen ich möchte eigentlich keine allzu
großen Veränderung weil wie es ist ist
es gut und jene Menschen deren Leben
eigentlich nur dadurch bestimmt wird
dass sich ständig etwas verändert
richtig wir haben also sozusagen die
hyperaktiven auf der einen Seite und die
anderen Seite die noch so ein so so ein
Stück Grönland in sich tragen die aber
trotzdem gezwungen sind sich an diesen
Fortschritt ja in irgendeiner Form
entweder anzupassen oder eben was eben
zunehm häufig passiert dagegen
aufzubegehren und gesagt ich habe diesen
Fortschritt nie unterschrieben ich habe
den nicht gewählt ich habe den nicht
gemacht ich will den nicht und daraus
entstehen dann gegenwärtig diese diese
großen
unzufriedenheitswellen ja diese
Abwehrreflexe ne die ja oft als
gespaltene Gesellschaft beschrieben
werden und der von dir gerade genannte
Steffen mau der findet ja den Begriff
gespaltene Gesellschaft nicht so gut der
findet den ganz furchtbar ne der sagt
das gibt es in Wahrheit gar nicht es
gibt Konflikte sagt er aber es gibt
keine gespaltene Gesellschaft in
Deutschland teilst du das ja also ich
würde mal folgendes sagen also gespalten
in so zwei zwei saubere Hälften ist das
natürlich nicht das ist eine
Übertreibung
ne das Interessante ist ja die meisten
Menschen mit denen man trifft ich treffe
ja viele Menschen ne Menschen sprechen
mich im Zug an oder auf dem Flughafen
oder so mit sehr vielen Leuten kommt man
bei vielen Dingen natürlich leicht in
einen Konsens und das ist auch das was
Steffen mau gemessen hat wenn er die
Leute fragt ist Nachhaltigkeit aus ihrer
Sicht ein wichtiges politisches Ziel
Ziel ne dann sagen die allermeisten
Leute
ja hat unsere Gesellschaft das Problem
dass die Schere zwischen arm und
reichweit auseinander geht sagen sehr
viele Leute ja an diesem Punkt gibt es
keine Spaltung die Spaltung kommt dann
wenn es darum geht was kann man denn
dagegen tun ne ist das heizungsgesetz
was Robert habbeck gemacht hat gut oder
nicht gut da gehen aber die Emotionen in
ganz ganz kurzer Zeit hoch ne das haben
die auch gemacht ne das haben die
getestet ich glaub 2500 Leute ne befragt
und sozusagen in der Art von von
Ermittlern ne die dann die dann beim
Verhör zuhören aber nicht zu sehen sind
haben die dann geguckt welche
Triggerpunkte muss man setzen damit dann
richtig der Blutdruck nach oben schießt
und das waren genau solche
Schlüsselwörter ne heizungsgesetz und
solche Dinge heizungsgesetz oder oder
oder Fam aus Gendern vegie Day und genau
ja also bei solchen Sachen entzünden
sich die Gemüter ganz ganz schnell
obgleich bei den großen Themen ne was
sind die wichtigen großen
Herausforderungen der Gesell aer sind
die großen Themen da sind die Leute
nicht gespalten aber wenn es richtig ins
Detail geht ja wohin hinter der steht ja
die Frage hinter veg Day und und gender
steht die Frage wohin soll sich die
Gesellschaft verändern und in dem Punkt
gibt es durchaus ich weiß nicht ob
Spaltung der richtige Begriff ist aber
da treffen Welten aufeinander wie wir
das gerade beschrieben haben da gibt es
diejenigen sagen wir müssen uns jetzt
stark verändern und dann gibt's diese
anderen Leute die sagen ich lass mir von
dir nicht sagen dass ich mich zu
verändern ja der die die schönen Sätze
aus der Politik die ich auch häufig höre
ist wir müssen die Menschen mitnehmen ja
das ist das ist so und ich denk dann
immer wohin wenn ich will vielleicht
auch gar nicht mitgenommen werden weil
ich mich gerade ganz wohl fühle wo ich
gerade bin ja oder auch so so ein Satz
wie wir müssen jetzt aber die Zukunft
gestalten ich sag den auch manchmal und
dann fängst du an drüber nachzudenken
und und du merkst okay das ist aber das
was die Leute was die Leute dann so
triggert wo die Leute das Gefühl haben
ne weißt du was ich gestalte den ganzen
Tag ich es muss mal gut sein mit
gestalten und das ist diese
veränderungserschöpfung von der Steffen
mau spricht zumindest ein super Buch ne
Triggerpunkte die haben zwei Jahre lang
ne haben die quasi diese Gesellschaft
vermessen und ich finde das eine
interessante These was also und auch
eine beruhigende Erkenntnis eigentlich
von von von Herrn mau der da sagt da
gibt es sozusagen so eine wie soll man
sagen eine ziemlich ideologiefreie Mitte
in Deutschland eine breite Mitte eine
starke Ideologie frereie Mitte so nennt
er das ja Ideologie ist auch überhaupt
nicht überhaupt nicht das richtige Wort
findest du nicht also ideologiereie
Mitte ist richtig aber ich meine das ist
ein völlig offensichtlicher Befund
Ideologien ja spielen in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft keine Rolle Gott sei Dank
Ideologien sind immer
Randphänomene aber gesellschaftliche
Debatten können sich trotzdem in der
Mitte entzünden auch wenn beide nicht
ideologisch argumentieren ja und das ist
das was er eben dann Konflikte nennt und
sagt das muss man dann auch mal
aushalten und und das ist auch okay sich
zu streiten aber aber sozusagen eine
echte Spaltung ich ich habe das gelesen
und dachte wie schön
also sozusagen gegen diese diese dieses
Mantra und dieses dieses wirklich das
eine Stanze eine flosklein Klischee
geworden diese gespaltene Gesellschaft
dass da einer kommt und sagt Freunde ist
aber nicht so und der sagt es ein
schöner Vergleich die deutsche
Gesellschaft ähnelt eigentlich an dem
dromeda einhöcker und keinem Kamel wie
in Amerika zwei Höcker das fand ich gut
ist ein schöner Vergleich es bildet ja
auch unser Parteienspektrum nicht ab ne
in Amerika wird ja mit mit Demokraten
und Republikaner werden ja auch zwei
zwei Hügel und zwei Höcker beschrieben
traditionell ne seit seit Ewigkeiten
einander
gegenüberstehend und das ist ja in
unserem Parteienspektrum gar nicht mehr
vorhanden wir haben ja beim letzten Mal
anlässlich der des Bündnisses von Saha
Wagenknecht darüber gesprochen wir wir
haben keine
rechtslinksgesellschaft mhm und und wir
haben auch keine totale
parteienidentifikation mehr in den USA
gibt es ja Leute die der Dynastien
Republikaner wählen oder Demokraten
wählen die also fest noch irgendwie in
diesem milieö sich verankert sehen und
das löst sich in Deutschland komplett ja
auf also das ist ja wie ein Supermarkt
ja wo man immer davor steht und überlegt
was soll ich denn diesmal wählen das ist
eine völlig andere Grundsituation als in
Amerika deswegen haben wir kein Kamel
weil wir nicht zwei Blöcke haben du du
gehst da genau rein in die Argumentation
von Christopher Clark den wir beide
glaube ich kennen ich hab hab den
mehrfach in der Sendung auch erlebt du
glaube ich auch ja Australier
Geschichtsprofessor ich glaube in in
Sydney geboren lehrt neuere europäische
Geschichte in Cambridge spricht aber so
gut Deutsch das hätte er nie außerhalb
Deutschlands gelebt ein ein Genie und
ein ein großartiger Mann weil ich so ein
feiner netter anständiger Mensch das das
meine Liebeserklärung an Christopher
klag ich finde ich finde er spricht ein
ein Deutsch als wäre Goethe sein
Sprachlehrer gewesen ich glaube es war
auch so ja das stimmt und Christopher
sagt etwas sehr Interessantes der
spekuliert in einem neuen Buch über
Parallelen zwischen 1848 und heute also
über wachsende soziale Ungleichheit über
die Unkenntnis der regierend den über
ganze Bevölkerungsgruppen das was wir
gerade erleben sage ich versteht gar
nicht mehr was wir auf dem Land
eigentlich für wichtig achten und jetzt
wollte uns auch noch das Schnitzel
wegnehmen und so weiter dieses
Misstrauen ne gegen die gegen die Eliten
dann auch
die schwinden Akzeptanz gegenüber
politischen Institutionen gegen
etablierte Parteien und so weiter das
heißt du hörst das und denkst oh mein
Gott wenn das damals so war es ist heute
wieder genauso und er sagt genau das was
du gerade beschreibst es gibt
mittlerweile eine Verflüssigung von
Politik das heißt n ich mit einem Freund
von mir drüber gesprochen der meinte
weißt du früher war einfach klar wo man
ist da war klar hier in der Siedlung
wohnt eine SPD Familie und in der si
wohnt vielleicht nette CDU Familie und
da wohnen liberale und so weiter das ist
heute nicht mehr so das ist das die
Verflüssigung von Politik und der sagt
das gleiche vollzieht sich auch in der
Medienlandschaft ja die Öffentlichkeit
verflüssigt sich so nennt er das Weg
sozusagen von von
mediastrukturen wie wir sie in der
Vergangenheit kannten große Verlage und
so weiter und Zeitungen Fernsehkanäle
hin zu Social Media völlig verflüssigt
und der sagt der die Gefahr die darin
liegt ist die der Konservatismus also
wir reden jetzt von Fredrich merärz von
der CDU für das was wir sozusagen für
konservativ
halten sagt die müssen jetzt besonders
stabil sein und er sagt und deswegen ist
der ich zitiere der aktuelle Amoklauf
der konservativen aus meiner Sicht viel
schädlicher als der Amoklauf bei den
Linken er sagt die Linken können sich
das quasi leisten aber aber wenn
konservative die von ihrem
Selbstverständnis ausgesehen
staatstragend sind ja wenn die nicht
mehr so handeln wenn sie Wahlen und
andere staatliche Institution nicht mehr
anerkennen Stichwort Trump in Amerika
und sagen ne nein nein nein das ist
alles geklaut und und wenn sie anfangen
verschwörungserzählungen weiter zu
verbreiten wenn man dann anfängt ne so
in den Vereinigten Staaten Trump ja
erzählt ständig irgendwelche
verschwörungsgeschichten oder oder auch
in in England gesehen und so weiter wie
sich die die die Tories da zerlegt haben
und du siehst solche Tendenzen auch bei
uns also ich finde es richtig dass
Friedrich
März bestimmte Themen anspricht aber die
Frage wie es macht das ist das Thema und
da denke ich manchmal diesen
populistischen Ausfallschritt würde ich
mir sparen und das ist glaube ich auch
genau das was was Christopher Clark
meint wenn er sagt ich ich flehe jeden
konservativen inständig an bitte wieder
konservativ zu werden Zitat ist ein GU
Satz mm das große Problem ist wenn die
Diagnose stimmt dass wir in Zeiten leben
die sich unheimlich an Tempo und Fahrt
aufgenommen haben also das des ganz
schnellen Wechsels und Wandels durch die
Veränderung der Ökonomie und die
Veränderung der Kultur und noch
Migrationsfrage und alles was damit dran
in Globalisierung dass in solchen Zeiten
hat es der Konservativismus unglaublich
schwer stimmt die Grundhaltung des
Konservativismus aller konservativen
dieser Welt ist wir sehr viel von der
Vergangenheit bewahren das ist das was
alle konservativen zusammenhält ja also
dieser Gedanke früher früher war es
nicht schlecht und wir wollen sozusagen
egal ob ich würde dieser These nicht
unbedingt zustimmen ich würde dem schon
zustimmen also gerade gerade auf dem ge
du dir selber zustim natürlich stimme
ich mir zu weil gerade auf dem Gebiet
der Kultur keine allzu großen
Experimente keine großen Veränderung
überlegt mal als ich Kind war und
Jugendlicher und das war doch nicht
schlecht und so das ist doch eigentlich
das was den konservativ zusammenhält nur
ein Gefühl ne ich habe das immer ganz
anders empfunden ich ich ich komme aus
einer sehr konservativen Ecke unsere CSU
heißt SVP und so weiter und da war immer
beides und so habe ich immer konservativ
sein auch verstanden und so erlebe ich
das auch Leute die da hast du recht
konservare ja bewahren ja das steckt ja
schon in der Begrifflichkeit Dinge
bewahren die uns wichtig sind Werte
bewahren die uns wichtig sind am Ende
auch wenn man es ganz groß macht
Schöpfung bewahren Natur bewahren
deswegen ist auch meiner Meinung nach
also konservativ zu sein der ist auch
eine eine ökologische Dimension ohne
jeden Zweifel ohne jeden Zweifel aber
viel nicht nicht ernst genommen das ist
ein ehrlich
gesagt nur nur nur den geden no zu
aber gleichzeitig auch sozusagen Zukunft
gestalten offen sein für neue
Technologien nach vorne gehen gucken was
geht das ist auch ehrlich gesagt so ein
christliches eine christliche Tradition
so habe ich das immer erlebt das ist für
mich konservativ sein also natürlich war
das so dass für die konservativen
Parteien in einer Zeit als die CDU sich
noch klar konservativ definiert hat
wirtschaftlicher Fortschritt technischer
Fortschritt unausgesetzt positiv besetzt
waren ja und das ist es für die CDU ja
auch heute noch aber und das ist das
große Problem wenn die Technik und die
Ökonomie schnell vorangaloppieren und
damit die Wirtschaftswelt verändern und
mit der Wirtschaftswelt die Lebenswelt
verändern dann kann manchmal Kultur
nicht alles bleiben wie es früher war
das heißt also diese typisch beirische
Kombination Laptop und Lederhose die
geht nur unter ganz ganz bestimmten
Bedingungen auf und die geht auch
vielleicht in einem Land das so
traditionsgeprägt ist und mit einer
solchen Wucht seine Regionalität
verteidigt wie Bayern auf die geht aber
schon in einem so heterogenen Land wie
die Bundesrepublik das inzwischen ist
eben nicht mehr ohne weiteres auf das
heißt die Konservativen kommen
regelmäßig an Punkte wo ihre Kombination
aus Technikbegeisterung und Ökonomie
muss voranschreiten und Wohlstand muss
wachsen und Globalisierung ist gut und
richtig auf der einen Seite und wir
wollen bleiben was wir sind auf der
anderen Seite nicht mehr ohne weiteres
aufgeht Migration ist eine Folge auch
der Globalisierung Migration ist eine
Frage der modernen Digitalisierung weil
die Menschen überall in Afrika jetzt
eine ziemlich genaue Vorstellung davon
haben wie es bei uns aussieht richtig
heißt also man bekommt dadurch neue
kulturelle Herausforderungen die man
eigentlich gar nicht gewollt hat und in
so einer Situation kommt der
Konservativismus und das ist ja meine
These in eine zwickmühlensituation da
stimme ich Dir jetzt auch zu
und ich ich ich wird noch ergänzen
wollen du hast natürlich dann ein guten
Punkt also wenn du wenn wenn Fortschritt
dann auch bedeutet ne Familien kriegen
dann weniger Kinder beispielsweise weil
Verhütung z.B auch möglich ist und dann
kommst du aber wenn es dann weitergeht
plötzlich an dem Punkt ind dem wir jetzt
sind dann schlägt der demografische
Faktor richtig hart zu ja und dann
brauchst Du plötzlich ja Stichwort
konservativ
sein wir müssen Einwanderung irgendwie
ah wollen wir eigentlich gar nicht und
so weiter Deutschland Einwanderungsland
wollen wir auch auf gar keinen Fall aber
dann beißt sich das plötzlich weil
plötzlich fehlen dir die Facharbeiter
die Leute die du brauchst und plötzlich
musst du anfangen nach ganz neuen
Lösungen zu suchen und zu finden und das
beherzt in die Hand zu nehmen und zu
gestalten Z recht ist ist tatsächlich
schwierig ja wir also natürlich wollen
auch die konservativen Parteien
Zuwanderung s wollen die Zuwanderung
genau jener Fachkräfte ja die im
Augenblick zu Hunderttausenden fehlen
oder ehrlich gesagt sind es ja nicht nur
Fachkräfte sind ja auch überall
Arbeitskräfte und wenn die nicht da sind
dann müssen die ja irgendwo ersetzt
werden jedenfalls solange wie der
technische Fortschritt nicht von sich
aus dafür sorgt dass noch zahlreiche
diese Arbeiten starker technisiert oder
automatisiert werden können und das ist
im Grunde stehen die Konservativen mit
dem Rücken zur Wand und ich glaube der
einzige Grund warum die CDU im
Augenblick noch stärkste Partei ist
liegt einfach daran weil es so eine
kollektive Unzufriedenheit mit der Ampel
gibt aber in dem Moment wo man wieder in
eine Regierungsbeteiligung kommt kommt
eben die große Frage wie kann
konservative Politik im Jahre 2023
erfolgreich aussehen und ich glaube da
kann man nicht einfach sagen wir machen
das so wie wir das früher gemacht haben
oder wir greifen die Themen der AFD auf
sondern da braucht man vielleicht auch
eine ganze Reihe neuer origineller Ideen
damit die Dinge bleiben wie sie mal
waren
ja und da kommt jetzt noch mal Steffen
mau ins Spiel der z.B auch
herausgefunden hat und sagt pass auf
also das was ihr da gelegentlich so als
vermeintliche
Themen die diese Gesellschaft Spalten
und so weiter herausholt das Lästern
übers gend und so weiter wenn du mal
überlegst wie viel übers Gendern auf
politischen Veranstaltungen gesprochen
wird und auch im Fernsehen kommt das
immer wieder den mal mein Gott noch mal
also ich versucht ständig Gespenster zu
vertreiben die außer euch wirklich
keiner sieht und Antworten auf Fragen zu
geben die nie einer gestellt hat und das
das finde ich finde ich wirklich
schwierig also die sich die meisten
normalen Leute nicht stellen aber die
sich stellen wenn du studierst dann
stellt die sich da musst du dir
überlegen ob du in der Seminararbeit ob
du da gender oder nicht genderst und so
weiter also dann stellt sich die Frage
in deinem und in meinem Leben stellt sie
sich weniger aber im Leben mancher Leute
stellt sie sich sehr stark ich habe aber
einen anderen Punkt ist es wirklich
Aufgabe von Politik und da meine ich
muss man aufpassen dass man Menschen
nicht wirklich noch zusätzlich zu allem
was schon auf uns so so so einprasselt
noch zusätzlich verunsichert und
wirklich wuschig macht ist es wirklich
die Aufgabe von Politik sich übers
Gendern Gedanken zu machen ich finde
nein macron macht jetzt auch so eine
Initiative Gendern verbieten ja das
Quatsch das ist ein sehr intelligenter
Mann und der liest unglaublich schlaue
Bücher und der hat echt was drauf und
man muss froh sein dass es ihn gibt aber
das ist etwas es enttäuscht mich von dem
weil ich denke jemand wie du der
ich weiß noch legendär in einem seiner
ersten Interviews im Spiegel beschrieben
hat welche äh deutschen Bücher er gerade
auf seinem Nachttisch liegen hat jemand
der so sehr von der Sprache kommt der
ein so brillanter Kopf ist der muss doch
klar sein dass Politiker nicht über
Sprache zu verfügen haben Sprache gehört
der Gesellschaft Sprache entwickelt sich
lass die Leute sprechen wie Sie wollen
es ist doch überhaupt kein Problem und
wenn du es nicht möchtest dann lass es
doch einfach dieses bisschen Toleranz
das werden wir doch noch aufbringen
genauso wie die Debatte über Transgender
und die
Frage geschlechterneutralität oder
Selbstbestimmung mein Gott s Marin die
ehemalige finnische Regierungschefin hat
den besten Satz dazu gesagt sagt weißt
du was wir sind so ein kleines Land und
wir brauchen jeden einzelnen in dieser
Gesellschaft es ist völlig egal wer oder
was er oder sie oder auch es gerade ist
völlig egal und genau so sollte man das
machen und das Verbindende betonen und
nicht ständig an dem Punkt auch noch
zusätzliche Spaltung in die Gesellschaft
bringen weil das ist nicht gut ja also
ich unterschreibe alles was du gesagt
hast ich bin genau der gleichen Ansicht
wie du aber unsere Liberalen
Gesellschaften tun sich mit dem
aushalten schwer ja ist richtig also und
dann zwar deswegen weil sie unausgesetzt
sich von populistischen Parteien bedroht
fühlen also macron macht das ja nicht
weil er wahrscheinlich ein großes
Problem mit Gendern das kann ich mir
wenig vorstellen sondern das große
Problem dahinter ist halt marine Le Penn
ja die die mit diesem mit diesem Thema
punktet die bei Umfragen gegenwärtig bei
30% liegt das ist ziemlich viel und ähm
das ist die krampfhafte Versuch der
regierenden äh zumindestens Teile des
Programms der rechten Opposition zu
übernehmen einfach um zu sagen na ja es
kostet uns ja nicht viel sowas zu machen
und wenn wir dann ein paar Stimmen
kriegen oder den ein paar Stimmen
wegnehmen dann machen wir das halt und
ein bisschen ähnlich ist es ja mit dem
was du bei Friedrich März beschrieben
hast auch ne da besteht ja auch die
Hoffnung den ein oder anderen CDU-Wähler
wieder zurück in den Hafen der CDU zu
holen und zu verhindern dass er
endgültig zur AFD abwandert da geht's ja
tatsächlich eigentlich nicht um Inhalte
sondern da geht es um wahltaktisches
Verhalten mhm das ist warah ich habe
neulich ein Interview gelesen mit Ivan
krastev den ich ähm heiß und den nicht
Liebe und der äh den du glaube ich schon
mal getroffen hast ne den hatte ich in
meiner Sendung es war eine der der
besten Sendung ein wunderbar kluger
unaufgeregter Mensch super mit einem
sehr weiten Blick etwas was unserer Zeit
sehr sehr dringend benötigt ja total
also bulgarisch bulgarischer Hintergrund
glaube ich bugare und Wien genau genau
schlauer Mensch der etwas Interessantes
sagte und das passt so gut zu diesem
Thema wenn sich große Dinge verändern
dann hat immer derjenige die größten
Probleme Achtung der das vorherige Spiel
gewonnen hat und das ist Deutschland die
letzten 30 Jahre krass ja waren so gut
sagt er dass die Menschen sich wünschen
dass das gestern nicht enden soll das
ist verständlich aber die Welt hat sich
plötzlich radikal verändert ne durch
durch einen Krieg von dem man dachte
sowas kann nicht sein die grüne
Transformation und so weiter ja und und
der sagt eben in den Jahren des Friedens
und dieses Wohlstandes hat sich eine
Mentalität ausgebildet die man
vielleicht so auf den Punkt bringen
könnte verändert ruhig die Welt aber
bitte nicht mal den Lebensstil und genau
das müssen die Deutschen aber jetzt tun
und das und das macht die Leute so
unruhig ja weil sie fragen sich wer wer
wer nötigt oder verlangt ihnen das ab
sie sagen sich wer ist derjenige der mir
sagt dass ich jetzt mein Leben verändern
will ja W wer ist das ein Politiker oder
oder oder oder Journalisten oder wer
will mir hier was vorschreiben in diesen
in diesen Jahren in denen es Deutschland
wirtschaftlich gut ging in den ruhigen
kel Jahren von denen wir nun alle wissen
was man immer schon mal befürchten
konnte dass es quasi die Ruhe vor dem
Sturm war ne in diesen in diesen ruhigen
Merkel Jahren hat sich natürlich diese
Mentalität eingebürgert ne Mutti mit der
Raute und es soll also bleiben und es
läuft doch alles und wir kriegen das
schon irgendwie hin und wir balancieren
das und so und wenn wir jetzt im
Nachhinein darauf gucken dann denken wir
immer klar in solchen Zeiten was da
subkutan passiert ja und die die Risse
die da in der Erde sind die fallen da
nicht groß aufmutti hat die mit der
Raute gekittet aber die waren natürlich
vorher schon da sonst könnten die ja gar
nicht so aufreißen das heißt es gab
sozusagen unterschwelliges
Konfliktpotenzial das jetzt eben
ausgebrochen ist ne dann das sich vorher
aber wahrscheinlich schon schon
abgezeichnet hat ist interessant ja noch
mal krassev auch ganz interessante
Beobachtung der sagt ihn beunruhigt dass
man bei den Massenprotesten ja zwei
Gruppen von Leuten sieht ganz
unterschiedliche Gruppen die etwas
verbindet und er nennt sie extinction
von links die gegen den Klimawandel
protestieren und eine andere Art zu
wirtschaften einfordern und extinction
Rebellion von rechts die Migration
bekämpfen und sich sozusagen von
liberalen Grundsätzen unserer
Gesellschaft verabschieden wollen und
der sagt es gibt Unterschiede zwischen
diesen Gruppen natürlich aber auch
frappierende Gemeinsamkeiten und zwar
z.B die Intensität ja mit der sie ihre
die Radikalität mit der sie ihre
Perspektive einnehmen ja die einglauben
wir müssen Emissionen sofort radikal
senken weil morgen ist es zu spät und
die anderen glauben wir müssen Migration
sofort stoppen weil morgen ist es zu
spät die einen wollen keine Kinder mehr
in die Welt setzen weil sie es für
Verrat an der Natur und an der Nation
und so weiter halten und die andere
sagen genau sagen mindestens drei weil
das ist Verrat an der Nation beide
Gruppen haben das Vertrauen in die
Zukunft verloren und wer keine Zukunft
sieht der hat natürlich Angst der
schlägt um sich das ist ein so guter
Gedanke das ein die beiden die haben
beide in Wahrheit kein Vertrauen in die
Zukunft das ist schlecht ich finde den
Begriff extintion Rebellion von rechts
sehr schön ja ja also ich find ich finde
ja wirklich also das ist sozusagen beide
haben Angst vom Aussterben ne genau die
einen haben haben Angst vom Aussterben
der Menschheit und die anderen haben
Angst vom Aussterben der deutschen
richtig kann man sozusagen sagen woran
die worin die die Trennlinien in dieser
Situation bestehen eine andere
Beschreibung für ein ähnliches Phänomen
ist ich habe mich ja unlängst mit dem
deutsch-israelischen Philosophen omri
Böhm unterhalten in meiner Sendung und
der spricht von rechter was allgemein
bekannt ist aber auch von linker
Identitätspolitik ja dieser Begriff
Identitätspolitik ist gerade so im
angelsächsischen Raum sehr umwog ne also
der berühmte Francis wukyama hat ein
Buch über Identität geschrieben und was
damit gesagt ist ist einfach dass in der
Zeit wo man das Gefühl hat oh die
Zukunft wird nicht gut und so weiter und
der Fortschritt geht zu schnell oder ich
komme in der Welt nicht mehr vor und ich
mag diese Veränderung nicht sie sich
Menschen auf ihre Identität besinnen
also nicht auf das was alle Menschen
verbindet ne die Menschenrechte und so
weiter sondern auf das was Menschen
unterscheidetm genau also ich besinne
mich daruf ich komme aus der und der
Region und ich will bleiben was ich bin
und ich will keine Veränderung das heißt
man fühlt sich plötzlich einer Gruppe
immer stärker zugehörig Stammesdenken ne
ja die die die Welt ähnlich sieht wie
man selber ne früher hat man das
Tribalismus genannt also Stammesdenken
heute sagt man eigentlich
Identitätspolitik dazu das Wichtigste
sind die Leute die aus der gleichen
Gegend kommen oder die die Welt genauso
sehen wie ich und dann baue ich mir
sozusagen meinen eigenen Stamm und das
sagt er ist eben nicht nur typisch für
rechts sondern ist auch typisch für
links ja ich glaube das ist einfach
typisch für Menschen oder na ja es ist
typisch für Menschen in Krisenzeiten ne
also in so guten Zeiten werden so werden
so Gedanken entwickelt wie das Leben
eines jeden Menschen ist gleich viel
wert universale Rechte Freiheitsrechte
für jeden ja und in Krisenzeiten kommt
dieses hauptsache ich und meine Gruppe
und das gibt's eben nach umriböm eben
auch von links ne ween man sagt die
wichtigste Frage ist bist du ein alter
weißer Mann oder bist du eine junge Frau
oder so wenn das sozusagen zu
Schlüsselkriterien werden dann ist nicht
Mensch das entscheidende Kriterium das
entscheidende Zugehörigkeit zu einer
Gruppe und das ist jedenfalls wie wie
böm das beschreibt und wenn das stimmt
ja dann würden wir jetzt im Augenblick
sagen wir erleben eine sehr starke
Rückkehr der Identitätspolitik etwas was
in den guten Jahren und in den ruhigen
Jahren eben nicht so ein großes Thema
war und was ich in Krisenzeiten vor
allen Dingen mit krasev gesagt ne man
hat den Blick die Schwärze der Welt im
Eingang des Tunnels ja und den Blick in
eine trübe Zukunft dann verstärkt sich d
was habe ich also nicht was erwarte ich
von der Zukunft sondern was muss ich
verteidigen mhm ich frage mich ja
manchmal ich hat abschließend noch mal
gefragt ist es wirklich so und sousagen
die die ganzen großen ideale und die die
Menschenrechte und all die Dinge die Du
doch gerade zitiert hast und die
Aufklärung und so weiter unser großes
intellektuelles Erbe um es jetzt mal so
zu sagen
m ist das wirklich das was uns
zusammenhält oder aber geht's in
Wahrheit am Ende nur um eins du kannst
alles das Vergessen in dem Moment wo es
den Leuten wirtschaftlich schlechter
geht wenn es ans Eingemachte geht in dem
Moment wo sozusagen der Wohlstand in
Gefahr ist dann ist alles andere
plötzlich nicht mehr wichtig egal was
wir uns vorher in sontagsreden
versprochen haben ja also das wäre das
ist die Gretchenfrage unserer Zeit ich
würde ungerne Antwort drauf geben ne
aber ich würde sagen diese Frage müssen
wir uns wirklich genau angucken also wir
haben ja
die schöne Erzählung über uns selbst in
der Bundesrepublik dass wir nach den
fürchterlichen Verbrechen des Dritten
Reiches gelernt haben ja wir haben
soziale Marktwirtschaft gelernt statt
Kommandowirtschaft
ähm wir haben äh gelernt
äh friedliches Land zu sein wir haben
gelernt uns selber als als Land der der
Menschenrechte zu sehen wir haben uns
tatsächlich in diesem Bereich auch in
allen Jahrzehnten immer weiterentwickelt
wir sind immer sozialeres Land geworden
wir sind ein offeneres Land geworden wir
sind toleranteres Land geworden also wir
haben eine sehr sehr gute Entwicklung
gemacht ne und das wird auch von von
vielen anderen Ländern ja an Deutschland
zurecht gelobt aber wir haben das alles
unter den Vorzeichen eines stetig
steigenden Wohlstandes gemacht es ging
uns auch immer besser und je besser es
uns ging umso juvialer wurden wir auch
und so unaggressiver wurden wir auch und
soo offener wurden wir auch ne und die
Angst davor dass wenn die
Wohlstandsentwicklung auf diese Weise
nicht weitergeht wir uns auch wieder
zurückentwickeln können richtig ich will
nicht will es nicht als Prognose
darstellen aber es ist zumindestens eine
Gefahr ich sehe das auch so also
vielleicht funktionieren liberale
Demokratien wie die Bundes Republik und
viele andere westliche Länder auch ja
nur dann besonders gut wenn es
tatsächlich eine kontinuierliche
Wohlstandsentwicklung gibt und was
passiert wenn die abreist oder wenn
dieser Prozess rückläufig wird wenn dann
Verteilungskämpfe natürlich auch
losgehen ne wenn politische Gräben
aufreißen wenn Politik radikaler wird
wenn die Stimmung der Menschen radikaler
wird die Umgangston miteinander weniger
liberal wird ja sondern immer weiter
zunimmen die erregungskurven zunehmen
das sind Dinge die wir jedenfalls
befürchten müssen und ich finde wir
müssen uns da jetzt sehr sehr viele
Gedanken drüber machen ja es ist das
Paradoxon sozusagen ne also die das
große Versprechen der Marktwirtschaft
der soziale Aufstieg für jeden
schaffbar aber wer erstmal aufgestiegen
ist hat natürlich auch in dem Moment die
Angst vor dem Abstieg und und und darin
liegt sozusagen die große Gefahr und ich
glaube das andere ist ein ein ein
Gedanke noch abschließend den Robert
Habel neulich mal geäusßert hat er sagte
bei uns werden sagen Misserfolge
individualisiert heißt wenn du es nicht
schaffst aufzusteigen ja das ist das
große Versprechen und jeder kann es
packen wenn du jetzt der eine loser bist
der es nicht schafft ja dann
individualisierst du das dann wirst du
gesellschaftlich sozusagen geächt nach
der Motto unter diesen großartigen
Vorzeichen haben es wirklich alle
gepackt aber du ausgerechnet nicht was
bist du für ein Versager und das ist das
ist ich glaube auch das spielt dabei
eine Rolle das das hängt alles
miteinander zusammen und das führt
glaube ich genau zu diesem zu diesem
Gefühl jetzt mal mach mal halblang ich
kann gerade nicht mehr ich glaube ganz
viele ganz viele Menschen hätten jetzt
mal das Bedürfnis nach einem Jahr
Auszeit in der
Politik so quasi dies Bedürfnis jetzt
mal ein Jahr irgendwie mal alle kommen
wieder runter und alle gehen zurück auf
Los das ist ja im augenblck glaube ich
sehr verbreitete Stimmung aber absolut
der große Robert hat gesagt in der
Geschichte der Menschheit gibt es kein
freiwilliges zurück also werden wir uns
auf die Weg machen müssen ein gutes
vorwärts zu finden ja sehr schön schöner
Schlusssatz Richard dank dir sehr großen
Spaß gemacht wir hören uns nächste Woche
fre mich all
tschüss eine Produktion von mhoch2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF